guess what the minimalists are going on
tour with a live version of the
minimalists podcast
and i want to invite you to join us for
a night of less find your nearest city
at the minimalists comm slash tour we'll
see you there all right Casey writes in
how do you stop yourself from
accumulating more clutter once you get
everything cleaned up okay so we often
treat minimalism as though it is a
destination but it is not a destination
it is a vehicle that brings you to your
destination right and so once you get
there so to speak you're at a new you're
at a new place but your life will
continue to change when I first embraced
minimalism at age 28
I was recently divorced and my mother
had just died I moved to apartment on my
own I was letting go of things it was
all about me and in my lifestyle but my
life changed over time by the way I was
still in the corporate world so I had to
have a certain number of dress shirts
and ties and suits and dress shoes those
things stopped adding value to my life
when I walked away from the corporate
world and so the best way that you can
do it is you can continue to ask
important questions and there are five
questions I always ask before buying
something new I'm not gonna go through
all five of those right now but you can
find those at the minimalists comm slash
b4 we'll put a link to that in the show
notes and you can also download the free
wallpaper with that so you can have it
right there on your phone or your
computer before you're about to buy
something you can look at your phone and
say okay well this thing I'd value to my
life is it the best use of this money
etc etc there are five really important
questions to ask before bringing
something in your life because once
you've decluttered you don't want to
reek Lotter
yeah we're talking about josh is setting
up rules for yourself and part of those
questions I mean that's a rule I'm gonna
ask myself these questions before I buy
something